señor ramírez gracias por atendernos en
france24 le pregunto qué opinión le
merece este informe de la onu dónde
detallan graves violaciones a los
derechos humanos y además lo más
preocupante con el conocimiento del
estado y la justicia del país
sí gracias por la oportunidad bueno un
informe demoledor es un informe que
viene a constatar y documentar lo que
han sido nuestras denuncias permanentes
que el gobierno nicolás maduro ha
convertido la represión y violación de
los derechos humanos en una política de
estado
fíjate que este informe tiene dos
vertientes una es la represión política
de la que hemos sido objeto todos
nosotros yo me estoy exiliado por
ejemplo pero otro ha sido lo que me duró
emprendido una especie de limpieza
social donde se han reportado en seis
años más de 24.000 ejecuciones
extrajudiciales que el gobierno dulce
que son de resistencia a la autoridad
ahora hablemos de otro tema que aquejan
a los venezolanos y de nuevo ese es uno
de los problemas principales del país la
falta de gasolina usted toma
expresidente de pvc de petróleo de
venezuela que es lo que ocurre
exactamente en un país con una de las
reservas de petróleo más grandes del
mundo
sí bueno maduro intervino a partir del
año 2014 pedevesa bueno han salido más
de 100 mil trabajadores nos persiguió
nos exilio hay más de 150 gerentes
presos secuestrados sin derecho a la
defensa y sencillamente en nuestras
operaciones se han venido el piso pues
no en el año 2014 que fue mi último año
de gestión en agosto del 2014 en nuestro
país producía 12 millónes de combustible
atendíamos al mercado interno con
600.000 verbenas y exportábamos 400 mil
barriles día de combustibles gasolina
dice es decir en 6 años no solamente las
refinerías están paradas sino que la
producción hoy día está apenas en 340
mil barriles de petróleo en la misma
producción que teníamos en 1930 maduro
intervenido pérez a la militar hizo a
partir del año 2017 y ha desviado sus
recursos para otros propósitos ahora
cómo se pueden normalizar entonces la
situación del combustible en venezuela
es tremenda porque este el problema es
que nuestras refinerías que tienen una
tremenda capacidad instalada no están
operando ni siquiera tienen suficiente
petróleo para alimentar las refinerías
entonces maduro ha tenido un pésimo una
pésima gestión al frente a la empresa y
la empresa pedevesa es muy compleja
ellos el día de ellos no es para estar
improvisando no y ahora se vino al piso
punto cero no saben qué hacer con la
situación pero eso tiene en el país
block down permanente en una encerrados
por el coronavirus porque no tienen
manera de garantizar el combustible para
el movimiento a la gente pues no hay
combustible en el país no se produce no
solamente no hay combustible cindy que
no hay gas tampoco la gente está
cocinando con leña lo cual era algo
absolutamente absurdo en el 2014 eso no
era así para nada y colombiano sabe bien
y en su opinión cómo se puede arreglar
esta situación que es grave para la
movilización además de los ciudadanos
dentro del territorio dentro de
venezuela
si yo lo he dicho el problema de
pedevesa no es un problema no es un
problema técnico tenemos suficientes
capacidades tenemos la reserva de
petróleo más grande del planeta un
problema político pues maduro mientras
maduro esté al frente del gobierno
nosotros no vamos a poder rescatar
nuestra industria petrolera él ha
intentado privatizar la violan a
nuestras leyes pero ni siquiera los
privados quieren hacer parte de una
situación que absolutamente irregular y
que viola nuestras leyes nuestra
constitución hay un problema de fondo
político en el país que necesitamos que
cambie para recuperar nuestro país
nuestras constituciones nuestras
empresas
cree que rápidamente una última pregunta
creo que esto le puede jugar en contra
al presidente maduro en las elecciones
parlamentarias de diciembre
esas elecciones están controladas por
maduro yo lo dije no se puede votar en
esta circunstancia y 47 millones
venezolanos que están fuera del país no
tenemos derecho al voto maduro controla
todo nada lo que se tiene que darse
cuenta el pueblo venezolano es que
debemos buscar la unidad de todos para
movilizando en contra un gobierno que ha
devenido una dictadura señor ramírez
gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en france 24 que tenga usted un
feliz resto de ella